The first formally recognized or organized black regimen and the civil war was
known as the first South Carolina volunteers.
It was organized and entirely and exclusively among freed slaves along the sea
islands of South Carolina.
He had had an amazing noncommissioned officer whose name was prince rivers.
Okay.
A man had been a slave yesterday,
but a free man by 1862
and whom
and who is white commanding officer Thomas weren't worth Higginson said in
another land and another time he could come in any army in the world.
Okay.
Thomas Wentworth Higginson was an abolitionist from Wooster,
Massachusetts who ended up the colonel and the commander of that regimen.
Nearly 1000 freed slaves recruited among the roughly 35 to 40,000 former slaves
along the Georgia and South Carolina Sea islands.
They're getting someone on to write a great book about it called army life and a
black regimen.
And among the remarkable descriptions,
you left in that classic is this description from Thanksgiving day 1862 so it's
November 62 the preliminary Manson pro emancipation proclamation is in place,
but the final emancipation proclamation hasn't quite happened yet.
It was actually the first formally,
legally,
federally recognized Thanksgiving Day,
so decreed by Abraham Lincoln
and Higginson had his headquarters in an old plantation house.
He looked out of broken windows
at this abandoned plantation and the sea islands through what he described as
the great avenues of great live oaks and he observed that quote,
all this is the universal southern Panorama,
but five minutes walk beyond the huddles and the live oaks.
We'll bring one to something so and southern that the whole southern coast at
this moment trembles at the suggestion of such a thing,
a camp of a regimen of freed slaves.
Almost two years later,
one of those freed slaves named George Hatton wrote a couple letters from the
front.
George Hatton was a former slave.
He had lived part of his life in Washington DC,
part of his life and Virginia,
North Carolina.
He'd been around.
He was at this point by April of 1864 a noncommissioned sergeant and company c
first regimen,
the United States colored troops.
They were in camp near New Bern,
North Carolina,
and he sat down to write a letter to reflect upon the circumstance that he found
himself in
Hatton.
His fellow soldiers and their families had lived generations of slaves
and this is what he wrote.
He says,
though,
the government openly declared that it did not want the negroes in this
conflict.
I look around me and see hundreds of colored men armed and ready to defend the
government at any moment and such.
You're my feelings that I can only say the fetters of fallen our bondage is
over.
A month later,
Hatton's regimen was in camp near Jamestown,
Virginia and he didn't miss the irony of being a Jamestown
founding side of Virginia
and into his lines came several black freed women
who all declared they had recently been severely whipped by a master
members of Hatton's company,
managed to capture that slave owner,
a Mr. Clayton,
the man who had allegedly administered the beatings on these women.
The White Virginia was stripped to the waist.
He was tied to a tree and he was given 20 lashes by one of his own former
slaves,
a man named William Harris,
who was now a member of the union army.
In turn,
each of the women that Clayton had beaten,
we're given the whip and their chance to lay the lash on the slave holders back.
Okay.
The women were given,
leave,
said Sergeant Hatton,
his words to remind him that they were no longer his but safely housed in
Abraham's bosom and under the protection of the Star spangled banner and guarded
by their own patriotic.
Though once downtrodden,
race,
and Hatton's letter,
he wants again,
felt lost for words to describe the transformation he was witnessing.
Yeah.
Oh,
that I had the tongue to express my feelings.
He wrote,
while standing on the banks of the James River on the soil of old Virginia,
the mother's state of slavery as a witness of such a sudden reverse.
The day is clear.
The fields of grain are beautiful and the birds are singing sweet melodious
songs.
While poor Mr. Clayton is crying to his servants from mercy.
Yeah.
That's a revolution described
in the words of a former slave words that we're trying to capture the
transformations of history.
At the same time,
his actions were trying to transform history.
Okay
words.
Now we will forever debate in this society the meaning of the emancipation
proclamation
over and over and over again.
We debate did it really free anybody?
Why did it only freed the slaves in the states and rebellion?
Why was Lincoln so bloody legalistic in this document was Richard Hofstadter,
right when he said it had all the eloquence of a bill of lading,
which means the grocery list.
Why was it written like it was a legal brief in court
here and they're laced with some remarkable phrases.
Why was he so careful not to free the slaves in the border states that hadn't
left the union and on and on,
but I think we should make no mistake.
The emancipation proclamation is a terribly important American document.
Emancipation is not just the story of great documents is I'm trying to argue,
but this one's important.
The second paragraph reads,
and this is by the way,
Lincoln's own handwriting.
This is a fast simile of the original.
He wrote some three or four originals that on the first day of January,
in this year of our Lord,
1,863 all persons held as slaves within any state or designated part of a state.
The people whereof shall then be in rebellion against the United States.
God is this legal?
Listic shall be then.
This is not legalistic.
Then Vince forward and forever free
and the executive government of this United States,
including the military and naval authorities there of the army and navy now
bound to do this.
It says,
we'll recognize and maintain the freedom of such persons and we'll do no act or
acts to repress such persons or any of them in any efforts.
They may make four there
actual freedom,
actual freedom.
No.
Yeah,
it was a limited document.
It didn't free as many slides as a second confiscation act illegally already set
in motion.
That's true,
but this is the most important thing to remember about the emancipation
proclamation.
Most black folks didn't care about the details of it.
Okay?
What they cared about is the,
that the United States government had acted and said they were going to be free.
Yeah.
There were at least four immediate and visible effects of the proclamation once
it went into effect on January 1st
okay.
Every forward step of the union armies now would be whether some of those
officers liked it or not a liberating step.
Secondly,
news of this proclamation,
whatever the details and the fine print would spread like wild flower.
I,
we'll have fire,
excuse me,
across the south.
Okay.
And it would bring about,
there's no question.
It will bring about increased activity,
increased flight and creased movement toward union lines by freed people where
they can do it.
And there's all over all over the record.
We have testimony of confederate soldiers themselves of southerners,
White southerners themselves saying they first heard about the emancipation
proclamation from their slaves.
Okay.
Third had committed the United States government in the eyes of the world.
And it's terribly important when we remember the Great Britain was on the verge
of recognition of the confederacy.
More on that bit later in the course of how that foreign relationship and the
problem of civil war diplomacy is being managed by the two governments union and
confederate
and forth
on the second page of the emancipation proclamation,
or is it the third and another very legalistic paragraph.
Lincoln formally authorizes once and for all,
although it's already begun to happen,
the recruitment of black men into the union armies
and navies,
and it authorizes a formal process to recruit black men.
Okay.
To the union uniform
and
before the war will end,
about 10% of all union forces will be African American,
approximately 180080% of whom were former slaves
from the slave states.
No.
In that fall of 1862 Frederick Douglass put down as cultural that he'd been
beating Lincoln with for a year.
And is that a tutorial?
Then?
He beat him bitterly at times.
At one point in,
in,
in the late 61 he called Abraham Lincoln,
the most powerful slave catcher in the world.
That was Douglas.
His opinion of that denial of asylum policy,
which said fugitive slaves escaping union lines had to be returned if their
owners were loyal.
Douglas,
like many others saw the nonsense in that policy early on.
Yeah,
Douglas finally put down the Cudgel
and he said,
lovely irony,
it is really wonderful.
Said Frederick Douglass,
how all efforts to evade,
postpone and prevent its coming had been mocked and defied by the stupendous
sweep of event.
It's coming,
meaning black freedom.
Okay.
And I'd just say lastly,
if at a fifth to that
emancipation transformed the purpose of the war.
Emancipation more than anything else will make the civil war war of conquest or
of near totality on both sides.
And it meant now,
now that this was going to be a war of conquest on the south social and economic
institutions,
it meant it for probably only end in unconditional surrender.
Now it's a complicated story as to how this will be enforced.
Of course,
and I strongly urge you to read certain of those Lincoln documents in the in the
Mike Johnson reader,
and more importantly to read at least that that greatest hits selection I
provided in the reading packet of the documents on emancipation,
which by the way come out of a book called free at last,
which is itself a 500 page collection of the greatest hits of the documents,
the American emancipation,
which are not published in five volumes,
all of which are in the library or in the national archives,
but one of those Lincoln documents I don't want you to miss.
I said to you the day was the James Conkling letter.
It comes August of 63
one of the reasons that letter is interesting is that it shows us that the
Lincoln could be one crafty politician
and whether emancipation will ever truly succeed in this war.
Of course depends on the union winning on the battlefield.
It really depended on all those deaths at Gettysburg and Vicksburg and so many
other horrible places and yes,
it's true.
The large,
large numbers of those union soldiers who died didn't necessarily believe they
were fighting to free slaves,
nor did they even want to.
But sometimes history is ahead of anyone's basic human individual motives,
isn't it?
But in this Conkling letters,
so called,
it's a public letter that link Lincoln mastered this presidential art of the
public letter more than any previous president.
And it was his version of the news conference,
which didn't happen in those days.
It was his version of it,
an exclusive interview with Anderson Cooper or whatever the hell it would be
today.
Um,
he wrote letters,
aim that certain newspapers,
which would then be reprinted across the country.
This was a letter to James Conklin,
congressmen from Illinois of his own party who was opposing emancipation,
who was it,
who was the least wary of it and worried about it.
The great worry about the man's patient policy of course,
was it white northerners would not accept it,
that white northern soldiers were thrown out on their arms and say,
I ain't fighting to free the slaves.
I'm fighting to preserve the union.
Thank you very much.
We can have that great fear himself.
Okay,
but God read that letter.
It's one of Lincoln's.
It's Lincoln,
the ironist.
It's also Lincoln,
the persuasive lawyer.
The second page of it,
he says to Conklin,
he's really saying this to white northerners.
Now is this,
this is letter have published everywhere you disliked the emancipation
proclamation he says in perhaps would have it retracted.
You say it is unconstitutional.
I think differently.
I think the constitution investments commander in chief with the law of war in
time of war,
the most that can be said if so much is that the slaves,
our property is there.
Has there ever been any question that by law of war property,
both of enemies and friends maybe taken when needed?
So there's that argument.
Whatever you think of the morality of this folks,
slaves were property of the enemy.
I'm taking their assets.
It's a legal argument.
Then you go to the next page.
He's also beginning to make their an argument.
If you read that part of the letter carefully,
it's an argument for total war to unconditional surrender and he's trying to
condition public opinion for this.
Did you go to the next page?
You say,
you will not fight to free negroes.
Some of them seem willing to fight for you,
but no matter fight you then exclusively to save the Union.
I issued the proclamation on purpose to aid you in saving the union whenever you
should all have conquered all resistance to the union.
If I show urge you to continue fighting,
it will be an app time then for you to declare you will not fight to free
negroes.
All right.
Crawl into your the and say you're only fighting to save the union,
but here's another way to save the Union
and then he goes on.
I thought that in your struggle for the union to whatever extent the Negros
should cease helping the enemy to that extent,
it weakened the enemy and his resistance to you.
Do you think differently?
I thought that whatever negroes can be got to do as soldiers leads just so much
less for white soldiers to do and saving the union
almost as if he's appealing to Conklin's racial self interest.
Does it appear otherwise to you?
And then Lincoln says,
but Negros,
like other people act upon motives.
Why should they do anything for us if we will do nothing for them?
If they stick their lives for us,
they must be prompted by the strongest motive,
even the promise of freedom and the promise being made.
Mohs B.
Okay.
Blah,
blah,
blah.
Lots of words,
right?
Words,
words,
words.
Yeah,
but meanings.
Xero,
almost always somewhere somehow and better than words.
No.
As I said,
now,
every forward step of the union armies is going to be oh,
liberating step.
And I want to show up just a quick map here to illustrate something.
Um,
I hope you can see the colors here to some extent.
The simple point of this map is this.
It's a map that shows the conquest of the South by union forces.
It's the movement generally speaking of union lines into the south and what
becomes now by 62 63 and 64 a war of conquest west and east.
But I want to especially stress that the most important factor in when and where
a slave might attain his or her freedom.
The first factor had everything to do with where the army's went.
It was proximity to the war that made emancipation possible in northern Virginia
and 80 60 to see islands of Georgia,
South Carolina,
62 around the whole New Orleans region in 62 but not possible at all.
And southern Georgia until after the war was over.
Not Possible really at all.
And Southern Alabama,
southern half of Alabama and told the whole war was over,
not possible at all and parts of Mississippi until the whole war was over.
Hence that's why the large majority of American slaves were not actually within
union lines or technically free in any way until the war ended.
Aye.
Make one other point about this does it as a nice book by a historian named
Steven Ash.
It's called when the Yankees came and it's,
it's all about the,
the process of union occupation of parts of the south.
He goes in and studies towns in Tennessee,
in towns in northern Georgia and towns in northern Virginia and tries to
understand,
so what happens when an area of the south end area of the confederacy came under
union control?
And he divides the south usefully here.
And it's very useful in understanding how emancipation actually happened on the
ground as a human,
sometimes brutal,
ugly,
chaotic,
painful process.
He divides the south into what he calls one at three regions.
One the confederate frontier,
the second he calls no man's land and the 30 calls garrison towns.
Now that's pretty easy to understand.
If you think of a,
this just take Tennessee up there in the middle.
Nashville became,
by 1862,
Nashville became a Garrett.
It was the capital of Tennessee.
It became a garrisoned union town.
That is,
it's occupied,
it's resources,
it's railroads,
it's,
it's everything were taken over by the union forces.
Okay.
And then there's the so called no man's land.
The region say between,
uh,
Nashville and where the confederate forces were,
the land between the army's,
which of course fluctuated a great deal back and forth.
Okay.
And then lastly,
he calls it the confederate frontier,
or at times he'll call it the confederate hinterland.
That is the land behind the line.
It was never taken by union forces.
Okay.
Land the land behind the lines were confederate resources.
Relatively speaking,
remained in tech.
There's still producing cotton crops
in the summer of 64 in the fall of 64 and they're still planting the whole
southern half of Georgia and the whole southern half of Alabama by and large.
Right on and 1865
but where you happen to be geographically was the first important factor and
where and how emancipation might occur in proximity,
particularly to the army's now a second factor that would determine when and if
slaves would be free,
was the character of the slave society in any given region,
were they in a densely populated slave region like the sea islands,
parts of the cotton belt?
Oh,
were they in sparsely populated areas
and it,
I mean again,
it had to do with geography.
Where are you in the Lower Mississippi Valley?
Huge concentrations of slaves when grants forces moved down to Mississippi.
Yeah.
And eventually take Vicksburg by July,
1863 this entire region,
the fact it is in the lower Mississippi valley.
This is why some people argue that the war,
the civil war was really won and lost in the West.
And I'll,
I'll engage that argument after the break when we talk about union victory and
confederate defeat and the various debates among his story and trying to explain
this,
a lot of people have argued that the war is won and lost in the West because of
the great significance of the Mississippi Valley,
which had become the great cotton kingdom of the world.
And when union forces truly conquered the Mississippi River by the summer of
1863,
there are thousands of slaves coming in to union lines.
The reason that grant and Sherman and other officers in the west begin to create
these things called contraband camps for freed slaves is because they didn't
know what,
what to do with them.
And there are these amazing dispatches written by grant,
uh,
to,
to the war department saying,
what am I going to do with all these people?
How do I feed them?
Where do I put them?
What is their status?
What are they legally?
And eventually it's why you get the largest contraband camps anywhere.
The largest ones were not in Virginia.
I'll go.
There was a huge one around Washington DC.
The largest of them were in northern Mississippi to place called Corinth.
You can see it on the map,
right?
There was a huge contraband camp at Memphis is eventually one in Cairo,
Illinois,
all up and down this region.
This is where conquest really happened first and that the true disruption of
southern society and the beginnings of the destruction of plantation,
it will lead even to the beginnings of,
it's going to,
it's going to take another year for it to happen along the east coast,
but it begins in 63 [inaudible] 62 but especially 63 where many plantation
owners in Louisiana and Mississippi started refugees.
They're slaves.
They would flee their plantations in the face of the Yankee armies,
often going west towards Texas,
sometimes just further inland or wherever they could go and they would try to
take their slaves with them.
It was called refugees and often what that means,
I'll,
I'll cite some examples of that after the break.
There's a famous diary memoir by a southern woman,
Kate stone,
who kept a diary of her plantation called broken burn.
At any rate,
she left with some hundred and some slaves to try to get out of Louisiana or
into Texas.
But the time she got there,
half of them were gone.
And she kept wondering why Ge,
why would they leave happened to their loyalty.
Then thirdly,
uh,
the third factor that would determine when and how and if a slave became free
was indeed,
um,
what policy was actually being enforced at any given time by those union troops
or for that matter,
by the confederate troops in terms of freeing slaves or not freeing.
So I was taking them into their lines,
are not taking them into the lines and establishing some kind of legal status.
And then the fourth factor,
of course,
and this one you can't measure,
you can know it when you read it and you see it,
you hear it.
And there's so many wonderful documents that demonstrated the fourth factor in
when and how American slaves became free.
What is it?
Their own ingenuity,
their own initiatives,
their own cunning,
their own bravery,
their own willingness to risk everything to try to get to something called
freedom
and not knowing what that freedom would be when they got there.
Would they be employed but their shelter,
we're going to be able to feed their children,
but they get their wives and husbands out with them.
What about women with three children?
Where would that go?
What would the status be?
Would they actually have any rights?
We learned much about this
and please in the,
in the,
uh,
reading packet,
have a close look.
I included some of those,
uh,
documents from the contraband camps where the superintendents of the de of the
contraband camps were all asked a series of questions.
They were asking things about the motives of the slaves that escaped into their
camps.
They were asked to describe why had these people come.
They were asked to describe their physical conditions.
They were asked to describe,
uh,
what they thought,
what they felt,
what they said.
And all these superintendents have all these contraband camps are just stunned
at the re at the way that black folk keep coming in spite of the hardships,
half close,
half fed,
if that,
and they're stunned at the religiosity of escaped slaves.
You superintendents right back and they said he's people singing their worship
all night long.
Strange,
but almost to a man,
these superintendents of contraband camps,
when asked what were the motives,
they simply fall back on the most basic of things.
They say things like,
um,
they wanted their freedom.
No maths patient also would depend here and there on a whole lot of other
factors,
but again,
they come under these categories.
I've already given you the close proximity to the war.
Now,
for example,
one of the war moved into Georgia in 63 and 64 when Sherman invaded northern
Georgia and the war really went to the deep hinterland.
The heart of the southeast
confederates were already,
and they're already doing this in Virginia.
They were,
they were beginning to do it out in the west.
They surely did it in the in the city of mobile and other confederate held
cities.
Confederates had begun to employ or impress their slaves into service.
Thousands of them,
about 3000 slaves were put to work in mobile,
Alabama building its fortifications,
slaves.
Hundreds upon hundreds of slides we'll put to work building afford occasion
fortifications of Richmond and estimated 5,000 slaves were put to work building
the fortifications all around Atlanta by late 63 to try to stop Sherman's
advance.
Very often they were hired out.
That is,
they were supposed to be paid or their owners were supposed to be paid for their
service.
They were used as teamsters in nurses and cooks and boatman and blacksmiths and
laundresses and so on and so forth.
If you saw a confederate army and eight from [inaudible] 62 to 64 you've seen
hundreds of black people.
Okay,
well,
and as those armies moved,
sometimes those slaves had opportunities to fleet in the wake of battles on any
scale.
Some slaves would always flee.
They were often
used as the burial crews on both sides.
They were also hired out,
and this was really significant in Virginia to the iron works in Richmond.
The tredegar ironworks at one point employed almost 4,000 slaves who tended to
be hired out from the western parts of Massachusetts in the northern parts of
North Carolina.
Okay.
That movement of people on this getting movement of slaves on this scale that
never happened in the south.
And in the midst of that movement,
Linda Morgan wrote a fine book on emancipation in Virginia and she showed this
for the first time that all of this movement of,
of hired out slaves to Richmond and other small iron works by the way,
over in the Shenandoah valley meant a certain percentage of them began to flee
and escape further north.
They worked on railroad crews.
Uh,
it was estimated that in,
in northern Georgia,
during Sherman's campaign against Atlanta,
that about 40% of all the women working as nurses and confederate hospitals all
over the state were slave women.
That means I had been taken off of their plantations that are farms or out of it
with their domestic situations,
wherever they were,
and put the work in the hospitals.
So the point is movement of the army's met movement of slaves as well and that
moment of freedom,
that moment of escape,
that opportunity might come when you would least expect it and that that
American slave had to make a choice every time.
Do I go and risk everything or do I not?
Let me tell you one little story in midst that it's the other half of this book
I just did.
So young slave named Wallace turnage.
He was born in a little tube on a little tobacco farm in North Carolina in 1846
green county North Carolina,
sold by his indebted owner to a Richmond Virginia slave trader named Hector
Davis,
who was one of the largest slave traders in the United States and kept enormous
records.
It's been about six months in 1860 working in the slave,
the three stories,
slave jail auction house in Richmond.
His job every day was preparing the slaves and what was called the dressing room
to take them out to the auction floor,
and one day he simply told,
boy,
you're in the auction,
and it was sold to an Alabama cotton platter planter named James Chalmers.
72 hours later by training,
he found himself on a huge cotton operation.
Your pickings Ville,
which is
all right,
right about there,
right on the Mississippi border plantation with about 85 slaves and the
narrative he left us,
which was discovered in lopped into my lap a few years ago.
The extraordinary narrative he left is the story largely of his five attempts to
escape in the midst of the war from the age of 14 to 17 he was one passionate,
half crazy one might say,
no doubt,
traumatized teenage slave who just couldn't be controlled.
He ran away four times in the Mississippi.
The second two of which certainly at least he was always trying to get up to
northern Mississippi to get to the union armies,
which he knew had controlled the whole northern tier of Mississippi by late
spring 1862 in fact,
three of his escapes over there.
We're really,
he would always go up the mobile in Ohio railway line at one time.
He was at large for four and a half months hiding another slave cabins and
hiding in the woods and forests and gullies and wherever he could hide and he
was always captured.
He was trying to actually get to Corinth and the big contraband camp and corn
and he almost made it on his fourth try.
Okay.
Kept being captured by slave patrols,
confederate patrols and so on.
His master would always come after him because he was so valuable.
He'd been sold by the way,
for $950 the first time out of North Carolina,
it was sold for $1,000.
The old [inaudible] in Richmond and Chalmers now got fed up in early 63 of
constantly trying to retrieve this kid and he took him down to mobile,
Alabama and soul limit the slave jail and mobile in the spring of 1863 for
$2,000.
That's about the price today.
Have a good Mercedes Benz.
Oh whoa.
As opposed to a bad Mercedes Benz.
I'm not sure what that would be.
Um,
and Wallace is fifth and final escape attempt.
The one that succeeded came after a vicious beating.
He'd been beaten many more times than he could count.
He'd been putting neck braces in leg chains and ankle chains and risks chains
and every kind of need to experience about it.
We kind of brutality slavery could wreck upon a teenage kid.
One day he crashed his master's carriage and a master got so angry he took him
to the slave jail,
hired the jailer to give him 30 lashes with the ugliest whipped they had.
This contraption,
they had the would make you bleed on every lash,
the end of any standing there.
Naked bleeding is master says go home.
Instead of going home,
he put his clothes back on and he walked right through the army,
a garrison of 10,000 troops where he was no doubt,
simply mistaken for yet another black camp pan.
And it does can you just crossed through the confederate camp and he walked out
of mobile and his final escape is a three week trek,
which she narrates,
uh,
in a,
in remarkable ways.
The three week trek down the western shore of Mobile Bay for 25 miles through a
snake,
an alligator infested swamp,
now known as the fall river estuary.
I've been there,
I've seen the alligators in the snakes from a large ferry boat.
Okay.
Then he describes one day praying especially hard when he got out to the tip of
mobile bay and the tide brought in an old rickety rowboat.
You tipped over the row boat,
took a plank of wood and it just started rowing out into the ocean and quite
dramatic form.
He,
which is no doubt,
a little embellished.
He describes how a wave is about to swamp is a little boat and he hears oars and
the ors were a union gunboat with eight sailors.
They said,
jump in.
He jumped in and he said as he sat down in their boat,
he said the Yankees sailors were struck with silence as they looked at him.
And I don't know if that's true or not,
but I don't doubt it.
They probably were struck with silence,
wondering who he was and how he got there.
They took him to a sand island fort and clothed him and fed him
the first kind acts by a white person,
the 17 year old turnage had ever experienced.
And the next day they took him to fort gains on Dolphin Island,
which is the big beautiful sandbar island on,
at the mouth of mobile bay.
And he was brought before the union commander of all forces in,
in the area,
uh,
Gordon Granger,
oh,
interrogated.
And probably because they wanted intelligence about mobile and Granger gave him
two choices.
He could either join the black regiment that they were forming at that very time
in the Gulf region,
or he could become a servant to a white officer.
And Wallace chose the ladder.
Didn't tell us why,
but probably because he'd had enough suffering.
He'd seen enough of his own war with the confederates and he served out the war
for another year as the mess cook for a captain from a Maryland regimen whose
name was Junius Turner
and Wallace was would that regimen in Baltimore,
Maryland in August of 1865 when was mustered out?
Yeah,
he lived three years in Baltimore and I moved to New York City where he lived
the rest of his life till 1916
but by 1870 I found him in a sense manuscript living on the 300 block of
Thompson Street.
What you and I called Greenwich Village,
he got his mother,
his four siblings,
somehow out of North Carolina,
and they were all living in a tenement house surviving as part of the first
generation of a black working class,
former slaves in a northern city.
He lived till 1916 he's buried in Cypress Hill cemetery in Brooklyn,
New York.
The point of all of that is that these slaves escape and we're real people with
real names,
real family,
real hopes and desires and those who survive.
Some of those who survived told us what it meant.
Now,
um,
the war of course rage don,
and at the end of the day,
it's a photograph whether we're taken an 1862,
I believe
I'm in Virginia.
The photographer simply called it
a group of contraband
or rage down.
And of course,
in the spring of 1863,
the union armies will invade Virginia again.
I'm going to come back the lots of this after the break when we get back to the
military history and try to explain how the union side won this war.
They'll fight are horrible battle at a place called Chancellorsville near
Fredericksburg and may of 1863 which will be another smashing victory by Robert
E.
Lee and stonewall Jackson over a union army commanded by Joseph Hooker.
It will give Lee his occasion for his second invasion of the north,
the riskiest of all,
which will lead him up through northern Virginia crossing the Maryland and
eventually all the way into Pennsylvania will lead to the fateful battle at
Gettysburg first three days of July,
1863 arguably the most important military turning point of the war,
but it is in those same first six and seven months of 1863 that this war has now
been transformed indoor of unconditional surrender,
a war of all out attempt at least all out mobilization at home and conquest in
the south.
It is during this period that black soldiers are being recruited.
The 54th Massachusetts,
the famous regimen from Massachusetts,
but I watch the movie glory was made,
was recruited that winter and spring of course,
and marched off to South Carolina to its fate,
um,
in May of 1863
they will reach to their fate at Fort Wagner,
the within a week of the battle of Gettysburg back up north.
But just as a way to take this out today,
back with me to July 1st,
excuse me,
January 1st 80 63 of the day,
the emancipation proclamation actually went into place.
I said at the outset that for most black folk,
they didn't really care about what actually the details are.
The words of the document where the point was that now somehow the United States
government was sanctioning emancipation
and go back with me at a Thomas Wentworth Higginson.
This is Higginson's description of emancipation day on Hilton head island,
South Carolina,
near Buford,
north,
uh,
Buford,
South Carolina.
He was given orders to read the emancipation proclamation to the people,
to the,
to the Friedman.
And this by the way,
became a policy throughout the union army.
Thousands of copies of the emancipation proclamation were given a union officers
who were ordered to spread it around the south Higginson not only spread it,
he held us a ceremony.
They built a little stage,
and this is his description of what happened
is describing the scene.
All this was according to the program rights.
Higginson then followed an incident.
So simple and so touching,
so utterly unexpected and startling that I can scarcely believe it on recalling
it though,
it gave the keynote to the whole day.
Okay?
The very moment the speaker had ceased and Justice I took in waved the flag,
which now for the first time,
men,
anything to these poor people,
there's suddenly a rose close beside the platform,
a strong male voice,
but a little cracked in elderly and to which to women's voices instantly blended
singing as if by an impulse that could no more be repressed than the morning
note of a song sparrow
my country,
tis of thee sweet land of liberty of thee I sing.
People looked at each other and then at us on the platform to see once came this
interruption not put down in the program firmly and irrepressibly.
The quavering voices sang on verse after verse my country,
tis of thee sweet land of liberty.
Others of the colored people joined in.
Some whites on the platform began,
but I motion to them to be silent.
I never saw anything so electric.
It may all words cheap.
It seemed the choke voice of erase that last on loose.
Nothing could be more wonderfully unconscious art could not have dreamed of a
tribute to the day of Jubilee.
That should be so effective.
History will not believe it.
And when I came to speak of it after it was ended,
tears were everywhere.
If you could have heard how quaint and innocent it all was,
just think of it.
The first day they had ever had a country,
the first flag that ever seen,
which promised anything to their people.
And here,
while mere spectators stood in silence waiting for my stupid words,
these simple souls burst out in their lay as if they were by their own hearths
at home.
When they stopped,
there was nothing to do but to try to speak and I went on.
But the life of that whole day was in those unknown people's simple song.
Have a good spring break.